welcome yeah my name is Raphael I'm a
data scientist at what X and I'm going
to talk about data science variety with
Python and spark
I added AWS in parenthesis just because
I realized that I mentioned in quite a
few AWS services throughout this talk so
this made sense and what I want to do is
tell you a bit a few things on how we
went about doing data science on Io T
sensors with in in the context of a
smart office prototype that we recently
built so I want to tell you a few things
a few data science e and data
engineering things that actually cover
the whole pipeline from the raw data to
pre-processing it a bit on modeling and
then with the ultimate goal of
essentially building a smart application
on top of IOT data and these are things
that for us tools and and and in recipes
and essentially very pragmatic
approaches that for us worked very well
while working on this on this prototype
and 30 minutes is way too little to
cover everything in detail but I hope to
give you an overview and a glimpse of
how we approach things such that if you
work with with this kind of data now or
at some point in the future you get some
some insights or some ideas to give you
a bit more background let me briefly
start by introducing ourselves and we
are what X where a company builds a base
in Berlin that focuses mainly on the
Internet of Things both for consumer and
industrial applications
and when I say company builder I don't
mean it in a sense of an accelerator or
an incubator but we really do everything
in-house from generating an idea to
actually spinning off an adventure so
we're a team of around 30 people
including IT engineers data Sciences UX
researchers business developers and in
all our other projects essentially
follow follow the same process and that
process essentially starts with an
ideation phase and in this ideation
phase we do our original research
in order to to create targeted ideas and
these ideas we move on into a discovery
phase and where we bulletproof those
ideas we look at the market we do
contact more user research evaluate the
technologies and and really make sure
that there is something behind that that
that idea that we end then moves into to
the prototyping phase and this is for me
and of course is the most exciting and
the most fun one because this is where
engineers and data scientists come in
and we actually start building a
solution for for for the original idea
that we had evaluate this idea in the
real world with actual customers and if
this turns out to be successful well
then we create we spin it off as a new
venture and use startups and takes over
the prototype and and and takes it into
market production eise's it so as you
see we work a lot with with prototyping
and move along those those those
projects in in a very fast way and so
one of the recent ventures that we found
is called snack and snack is is it
essentially provides an infrastructure
for enabling smart building applications
so much of what I'm talking about now is
what led to to actually spinning off the
company so these are the four points
that I want to go through first of all
give you a short introduction into this
smart office ayat eat set up what kind
of data that we use how did we get it
into the cloud then move on into into
some pre-processing what did we do in
order to transform the data such that we
have it in the format that we like to
work with and then give you an example
on how we modeled a sensor data that is
a machine learning approach to do time
series forecasting here I want to
concentrate on the general approach
itself not not on the models and then
the last bit would be on scaling and
automating things by adding SPARC on top
of our Python code and deploying
everything on on AWS so let me jump
straight into the smart office IOT set
up here are a few numbers essentially we
had access to two two floors of an
office building in in Germany comprising
36 rooms and where we installed over 200
and we recorded data for a period of
around three and a half months here you
see a sketch of one of the floors where
the dots denote install sensors in the
rooms as well as in the hallways these
are the sensors that we used those are
so-called multi sensors because
essentially it's it's a single device
that contains several sensors four of
them which are temperature luminosity
humidity and motion and those devices we
essentially installed on the ceiling of
the building in smaller rooms there was
a single of those and in bigger rooms we
installed several of them just in order
to cover the whole space and so let me
show you how the data flow goes of
course the data starts at the senses and
the senses sent the data to to the
gateways and the gateways are just small
computers that are connected to the
Internet the protocol used here in order
to communicate between sensors and
gateways and was was he wave that is
something that we use back then because
we just needed something that worked out
of the box but in the future we will
definitely go with something different
and then so the gateways we had one of
them per per floor and the Gateway sent
the data into the cloud using using
Wi-Fi and as I mentioned before AWS is
the cloud infrastructure of our choice
so in this case we are using the AWS IOT
service which if you haven't heard about
it in its core it's essentially just an
empty TT broker which is very common in
in IOT M in IOT in general and and this
MQTT broker just has a few services
around that this is very similar to
other IT platforms the nice thing about
this is that we can connect us very
easily to two other AWS services so what
we did here is use a Kinesis firehose
cue pull the data out of this broker and
simply pipe it into a 3 and a 3 as being
our blob store where we essentially
stored all our raw sensor data and this
for us was the starting point for the
data scientist this time seemed to come
in and and start working on on this kind
of sensor data so let me move on and
show you a bit of the data and what we
did in order to pre-process it here you
see a snapshot of I hope you can see it
as well
yeah this is a snapshot of the raw data
and essentially one data point consists
of three values a sensor ID a timestamp
and a value this is essentially very
common for for for time series data that
is what we call the observations format
because essentially each row is one
observation of a particular sensor at a
particular time emitting a certain value
and it has to be noted that our defenses
they don't send a data point at regular
intervals but most of them are
configured such that they send a new
data point once they sense a change in
in whatever they're measuring so a
temperature sensor is not saying every
minute the temperatures 25.1 but it says
once twenty five point one and the next
data point is is whenever the
temperature that it senses changes and
so what this means in terms of raw data
is that all of our sensors across
sensors and within sensors the time
stands are very very irregularly and and
this this becomes important in a minute
on top of this of this raw data what we
also have in the cloud is is essentially
a metadata file that for each of these
sensors gives us the meta information
such as of what type are you what floor
are you installed in in what room are
you online and offline and so of course
this is information that we need and
instead of instead of sending it with
with each coming data point which which
would be just highly redundant and a
huge overhead we just have this this
made a data file that that gives us this
information that we then later can use
to do simpler group buys and
they retrieve all the data of all the
sensors within one room for instance and
so what we do in in terms of
pre-processing is that we go from from
this observation format that has this
three column structure of sensor ID
times time and value and we pivot the
data such that we end up with a data
frame that has a single day time index
and each column now represents all the
values of of one sensor this this is a
very natural way to think and to work
with with with this kind of data I think
because all the values of a single
sensor are just aligned in time within
one column and the key point here is
actually that now all these timestamps
that I just mention are completely
regularly to start with we unify them
and we align them in order to have
regular intervals between these sensors
such we can easily say give me all the
values of all the sensors in this room
this morning at 9:15 right without to
have without having to deal later on
with converting time stems and and
changing them and aligning them and all
these kind of things so they keep the
crucial operation that we need to do
here is is for each sensor resample the
data to go from this regular timestamp
format to to a single one and if you
talk about resampling and we live in a
Python world then ultimately we end up
with pandas because pandas has this very
nice resampling functionality where
essentially for any data frame or
serious object that is daytime index you
can simply call resample give it the new
interval that you wanted in provide a
resetting method in this case it's the
mean and your resulting data will be in
this in this new frequency to show you
just a toy example this is just just a
lion think of it as let's say
temperature rising or something this is
they
index has a frequency of 30 minutes and
so let's say we wanted to go from these
30 minutes to 2 to 7 minutes well then
we essentially just called resample say
7 minutes use the mean as resampling
method and interpolate linearly between
the resulting values because in order to
fill essentially non gaps that result
from going from from from the higher
frequency to from a lower frequency to a
higher one the difference between this
sort of toy data and our senses as I
mentioned before is that our senses
don't have a particular starting
frequency to start with so it it's very
regularly so by doing these resampling
operations sometimes we're actually app
sampling if the sensor data is very
sparse or
depending whether it's very sparse or
very dense so we get very different
results across across the senses and so
what what we did here is a very simple
trick of doing this resampling in a
two-step process where we first up
sample all of our sensor data - to a
very high frequency let's say a minute
and then down sample again - to the
desired frequency that we actually want
to end up with and this works this works
actually very nice so in this case it
will look something like up sample
everything - a minute again use the mean
a3 sampling method interpolate linearly
and then because our target frequency is
seven minutes we down sample again - to
the target frequency and now we forward
so because we're going to from from from
high frequency that is one minute to two
to seven minutes and so apply it to to
actual data this is a temperature curve
the blue one as the original data and
then you see that the resample points in
this case piece in 15 minutes match the
the underlying data very well here's
here's another example of a noisy sensor
where you have these periods of of very
sensitive periods of those sensor
jumping between
- values and then you have these periods
of where the sensor is constant and
again here applying these resampling to
to this regular frequency works very
well and so the data that we end up with
this time series format essentially has
this this day time index and and and the
columns now are the sensors that we then
simply can join arbitrarily as we want
and work with them together so this is
this is what I wanted to say on on
resampling for us a very important step
to do before we move on in order to to
actually start working with the data we
have it clean we have it in this format
and so third thing I want to talk about
is is applying machine learning on the
sensor data and specifically use a
machine machine learning approach in
order to do timeseriesforecasting so
this project essentially for our data
science team was the first one in which
we had to deal with with time series
data so we didn't know too much about it
but we were very very familiar with with
Python essentially experts in within the
Python data science tech numpy and
pandas and scikit-learn the usual
suspects so we were thinking ourselves
how do you now go about of using that
knowledge of like how we've always done
data science and modeling by using one
of the scikit-learn models how do you
actually apply it on this kind of time
serious data in order to do forecasting
and so here's the here's the approach
that we took and I want to show you this
with the example of an occupancy
predictor so predicting an occupancy in
a room is simply saying for some time
for some point in the future I want to I
want to know is this room going to be
occupied or not so we have these these
intervals of hourly intervals let's say
of you can see values and a time point t
that is now I want to know is this room
going to be occupied one hour from now
what about two hours from now three
hours from now
so what we end up with is a binary
classification problem with multiple
steps ahead okay and so if we if we
would do to formalize this then we could
end up with something like this where we
have some some historic data and some
some X's can be motion values or other
features and we want to learn this
function as this model that can be
essentially any scikit-learn model and
predict for a certain step in the future
is the room going to be occupied or not
and but we don't want to do this for a
particular step but for multiple steps
so here's three strategies that we used
in order to approach this the first one
would be the direct step approach where
essentially you you train a model in
order to predict one step ahead and then
you train a completely separate model in
order to predict to two steps ahead and
so on and so forth so for every step
ahead that you want to predict you you
have a separate model the downside of
this of course is that you end up with
this computationally very heavy because
you for each new target for each step
you're training a new model and if you
extrapolate this to to all the rooms in
your building you end up with with with
a high number of models and the second
downside is that essentially you use
this predictive this the temporal
dependency between predicted values
because the prediction at T plus 2
doesn't know anything about the
prediction that keeps us 1 it was
trained and predicted completely
independent from each other so another
approach that you can take to to do this
is through three turret of steps and
what you do here is you learn a model to
predict the next step and and then you
use you predict that step and you use
that prediction and feed it back in into
the model at in order to predict the
next step and so on and so forth you do
this for as many steps as you want to go
forward so now we have only a single
model but the downside of this is
and that you're essentially accumulating
an error as you go into the future
because you're always using the
predicted value to feed it back in into
into to your models to predict the next
step so as you go forward the prediction
error goes up and so what we ended up
doing is the third strategy and that is
multi-layer prediction where we state
the problem the same but now we are not
trying to predict a binary binary value
but but an array of binary values where
this array essentially are all the
targets of the the steps I had that we
want to predict and so nice about this
is that this can be actually used with
any model that that supports multi-label
prediction and in scikit-learn there's
quite a few of those and and where we
ended up with what ended up with and
doing is it simply implement in a coupon
C transformer that lets say having some
some motion data compute some features
for us gives us the data and this format
such as we can train an algorithm this
way and in feed it into a random forest
classifier that actually supports
multi-level prediction out-of-the-box
and and this actually works very fine
there's there's this guy named Tomas
Huskins I don't know her myself but I
think he's Dutch so maybe the community
here knows him and and he wrote actually
a very nice blog post on exactly
timeseriesforecasting using this machine
learning approach where he goes through
these different strategies and and so if
you want to go into this
I really recommend reading is it's very
nicely written very simple and it gives
you a good idea of what I just talked
about just to give you a preliminary
result here's the AC values of one of
our predictors for a particular room six
hours into the future and the
corresponding AUC values of course it's
cherry pick this is one of the rooms for
which it worked pretty nice actually so
there's the
quite quite some variance across rooms
because if you think about a very common
office room where where someone comes in
at 8:00 and then states until 12:00 and
then there is an hour of lunch break and
then there's another five hours of of
being occupied and that goes on five
days a week these visas of regular
occupied rooms are very very easy to
predict as compared to let's say a
meeting room and we had other funny
incidents of rooms being occupied during
the night in the kitchen and it
essentially turned out that apparently
the the night guard you'd like to hang
out in the kitchen for a few hours so
yeah and we had we had another and IRA
funny incident were in two of the rooms
we installed a net atmo device which
essentially tracks the co2 level and we
were building applications around it so
on a Saturday night we got we got a
notification saying that the co2 level
was two times higher than the
recommended values and turned out that
the office was having a party at this
that evening and that's why that was the
case guess ya still have some time let
me let me move until the last part which
is automating and scaling so the way
that we work in our data science team is
we we work locally we use panels and
scikit-learn and work in our jupiter
notebooks and work on subsets of the
data say you know train one of these
predictors for a room or on a few senses
and so on and so forth
but what's missing in order to actually
build a smart application is now to take
these these different steps that we now
build of going from raw data is your
pre-processing into training a predictor
to doing actually some predictions and
so on and so forth automate this in a
pipeline and and actually run this on a
regular basis because for each new
incoming data we want to actually update
get our models we want to we want to
retrain them we want to do new
predictions and so on so automating is
is crucial here and B and the other
thing is scaling if we if we train an ik
you can see predictor we don't want to
do this for a single room but
essentially for all the rooms in our
office independent of whether all means
2 or 36 or a few hundred and so what
what worked out for us here very well is
the combination of using spark on on on
top of EMR I assume that you all know
spark or you know what spark is let me
put it that way and EMR is is the
elastic MapReduce service on AWS and
what it actually allows you to do is
simply bring up a cluster Hadoop cluster
and run spark applications for instance
on top of it and that's how we use it
and it has this very nice functionality
where you can actually programmatically
tell EMR bring me up a caster run all
these steps all these part applications
in this order and when you're done take
the cluster down again automatically so
by using EMR we're actually achieving
this automation because we have this
pipeline of different tasks that we can
run ends and by doing this in SPARC we
achieve scalability for for this for
this prototype and the way we use SPARC
is not that we reimplemented in pure
Python our scikit-learn models we don't
reinvent animals part because our our
problem so far hasn't been that the data
of a of a single room doesn't fit into a
single node so if that's not the case we
don't need to reinvent things but we
actually use SPARC and it's its power of
parallelizing things in order to do what
we did for a single room across all the
rooms in in the building or we paralyze
across excuse me
sensors depending on on what what we're
trying to achieve
so let me give you a very simple and
boiled down example of how a spark
application looks like that that such
that you get an idea of how we use it of
course we use PI spark and for those of
you who have used part before you know
the first thing we need to do and when
we build a spark application is
initialize as far context which is
essentially our window into to the
Python world and to the spark world
sorry and and then we have this this
function that for all the rooms in in
our building just gives me all its
motion sensors so let's say we want to
train an acute NC predictor based on on
historic emotion values so this room
census variable what it essentially is
it's just a list of tuples where the
first entry is the room ID and second
entry is a list of motion sensors and
what we can do with this is simply
paralyze it in SPARC and now we end up
with an RDD of key value pairs where the
key is the room ID and the value is this
list of motion sensors and now for
whatever we did locally on a single room
we simply apply it on this r DD and and
and in this case for instance a function
that loads some some sensor data and
then a second one that and for each
entry of this our DD of trains a
predictor and serializes it somewhere so
this is sample spark application of
course this is very very boil down to a
minimum there's more to it but just for
presentation purposes and to give you an
idea on how we use it
I made it compress it a bit and and now
now we actually implement all these
Sparkle equations that go through that
essentially do whatever we want them to
do and go through this through the steps
and now we want to run those in in on
EMR automatically and for this we can
again use use Python and if you have
worked with AWS and Python the library
to use is is both 203
and in order to talk to this AWS
services so what we do here is we get an
EMR client that talks to the EMR service
and we run the run job flow function and
that's that's a very nice function that
essentially does what I told you before
it brings up a cluster runs a number of
tasks and then brings the cluster again
automatically and so in this case I'm
just creating a cluster and telling you
to give it this name I want this many
nodes of this instance type and there's
actually much more configuration to this
that we actually use again for
presentation purposes I'm boiling it
down to the minimum and then the two
important steps here are these bootstrap
actions and and job steps and the
bootstrap actions essentially are just
very small scripts that you run in order
to to configure your cluster such that
we use it for instance just to install
our Python libraries across all nodes of
the cluster so if we're using
scikit-learn and pendous well then we
use bootstrap actions in order to - - to
install those libraries and the job
steps are the actual spark applications
that are then being run in this order so
this is an example of the job steps
these are to spark applications one that
does the conversion from observations to
time series this is paralyzed across
sensors in our building and the second
one is paralyzing across rooms and for
each room and spark application the
trains and an occupancy predictor here's
an example of the bootstrap actions it's
actually only this installed libraries
shell script and what this contains is
literally pip install and then the
libraries that we actually want to use
the dependencies of our spark
applications it's really as easy as that
to put everything together and you
already saw this our data that goes from
sensors to gateways to AWS IIT firehose
and ends up with with s3 and then the
second part of this data flow could look
something like this where we have a
three we we run we load the data we run
these the
PMR jobs parallel lies our Python code
using spark across fences or rooms and
then for instance we save predictions
that we do we save them into dynamodb
and and we can plug in a a small as
flask API in order to serve those
predictions of course is the step in the
end it just depends on the use case that
you have of whether what you're actually
using your smart mouth smart application
for so that is all I have here's the
summary of the things I've talked about
I'm just going to skip through this I
just want to mention a few things I did
not talk about things that we are
working on or aiming to work on one
thing that I did not talk about is
stream processing and so everything that
I mentioned was was essentially batch
processing you take big chunks of data
and you process them that way but for
applications that require more that
where time matters actually we're
starting to look into sparks streaming
patchy flink and these kind of
technologies that that enable this then
I mentioned before how we use spark that
we are actually not using it to to for
for fruits using its actual libraries
but just to paralyze our scikit-learn
code for cycler models for instance but
of course as data grows or as we are
building models that don't only use the
data of a single room or off a few
senses but it gets as big as it doesn't
fit into a single node then we we start
implementing things in in SPARC and
actually making use of these
technologies much more third thing is
modeling I approach that I mentioned is
just one of many in order to do time
series and there's more traditional ones
such as Markov chain Monte Carlo methods
we want to look into Alice TMS that are
very suitable for time series data
yesterday there was a talk on deep
learning on on time series which is very
nice in order to classify time series
I'm serious curves called McFly this is
something we definitely want to check
out and then the last bit is actually
closing the loop and using these these
smart these predictions that we are
actually producing in order to control a
device so one of the motivations for
credit for creating such an occupancy
predictor is to actually use those
predictions and control the heating of
the room if we know that someone's going
to be the in this room in one hour and
we have temperature models so we know
how long it takes for temperature giving
a current condition to reach a certain
level and then we actually want to
control the valve of a radiator let's
say in order to to heat or cool down a
room all right this is so really all I
have I feel like I talk so fast I hope I
didn't lose too many of you in the
meantime thanks for being here and thank
you for your attention